I was discussing the value of hyperbaric oxygen to a hyperbaric oxygen tank with a de-o-friend
of mine and a question came up, does hyperbaric oxygen increase the metabolic activity of hyper-metabolic
malignant cells? I haven't seen any evidence of that. So this is the difference between
increased O2 and increased O negative. So understand chemistry a little bit. Hyperbaric oxygen
increases oxygenation of tissue, increases O2 which can really help with cells. I don't think
it increases metabolic activity of malignant cells. Matter fact, there's enough studies that show
that it helps with cancer. The only thing I have negative against hyperbaric oxygen is that
it's you almost have to have a hyperbaric oxygen tank in your house because you have to
all the studies that have done hyperbaric oxygen have done it on a daily basis. And it tends
to be better for brain issues. Hyperbaric oxygen really shines with brain cancer and brain issues
and dementia issues. That's where hyperbaric oxygen really shines. For colon cancer, for liver
cancer, it's pretty iffy. And it takes time, you know, you're doing it for at least an hour
every day. So, you know, it's not one of my favorite therapies for that thing. But if a person
has brain cancer, hyperbaric oxygen would be something that would be viable to add.